i have 100 minecraft players here and
100 plots of land and whoever creates
the best farm
wins 50 000 5-0
wait jimmy why a far because the sponsor
of this video
is dairy that's utterly insane milk 100
players 100 plots of land
50 000 on the line server give them
their plot
as usual carl and chandler are competing
go to your call what up contestants
whoever makes the coolest form
wins fifty thousand dollars
i don't know what you're saying but i'm
gonna leave hello mike
okay i'll start making the farm house
itself what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
make a path
just because we told everyone to build a
form and uh i guess he's making a barn
i'm
giving cows to chandler and carl oh
shoot
cow what is he doing stop no
we don't need cows yet i'm gonna just
keep feeding the cows so they keep
making babies
stop there they go what is this this
doesn't look like a farm
i wonder how many people are gonna build
red barns well if you look
back from this angle it looks like
everyone
red barns wow look at all these
farmhouses
okay i'm gonna make this double the
height of the other section jimmy look
this guy needs to install source what is
he doing
it's like gary's mod when it goes wrong
that's what sources
i'm just leaving oh my god that windmill
oh my god
that is made by our people yeah our
builders are really awesome
how are these cows dropping cocoa beans
is this doo doo
this guy's making a giant pig we're
gonna move this guy
into the chat cuddy kid welcome to the
call hey what's up we have a problem
this is a farming challenge and among us
isn't a farm well it's a farm for views
it is a farm for views look at all the
views it's got but it's not a real farm
watch you'll see the greatest farm
you've ever seen all right i believe in
you man oh there's a guy stuck in here
oh no
look this poor guy i got you bud
there you go oh yo how's the water
looking from above hey you're inside of
the house
get the cows out of the house all right
so carl's working on the house i'm
working on the farm we're doing things
working together wait this actually kind
of looks good
they're like no no
fifty thousand dollars on the line carl
what do we do now while everyone is
building i want to tell you about the
sponsor of this video america's dairy
farmers
america's dairy farmers wanted you to
know that 95
of farmers large and small are actually
family-owned and in case you don't know
drinking dairy is linked to some health
benefits like reduced inflammation
and a stronger immune system and in a
really pro gamer move
dairy farmers of america are aiming to
be carbon neutral by 2050. now that's
epic
on top of that they are committed to the
wellness of the cows and they are only
milked for around 20 minutes a day
and i actually talked to one of the
dairy farmers in connecticut that is
taking the manure and making
biodegradable planting pots they're
making sure nothing goes to waste drink
milk and let's go back to raiding these
farms
i'm partially colorblind chandler come
over here this is clash of the brick too
much
yes that's ugly i'm a city boy almost
say
boy holy crap we're getting wrecked
right now
meanwhile
you know what chris what you know what
it's really got me sad what
the fact that i don't see a single bruh
meme that's how you know 2020 is bad are
you really a mr beast gaming fan if you
sacrifice oh really wait where
he combined bruh meme to bream and now
it's
bream farm what are the odds you find
this as i'm getting sad
that was really weird something like
this what is this
what is this one i it looks cool does
this look like the front of a farm
sure no this isn't a farm a desktop
is not a farm he might be farming crypto
with his computer
stop no this person has actually created
a farm let's see what chandler and carl
are doing oh this dude built a windmill
no chance somebody made a windmill okay
i'm not gonna lie i don't know how to
make a freaking farm
all right just start hoe in the ground
what did you just call it carl it's a
farm tool and what is this supposed to
be clouds or something
well chris your cows are running away
everywhere they're migrating she said me
and my children will find a better host
look at all these epic builds and then
this empty plot i guess someone didn't
want 50 grand
i don't know what this guy's building
but move him in the chat what is up bob
hi based on what you're building i don't
think you're gonna win the 50 grand
okay so instead of competing bob do you
want to just be one of the judges with
us
yes definitely yeah we got bob this day
has been crazy because first
i had surgery today and now i'm a judge
what was the surgery
i had to have a tooth removed because it
was still a baby tooth that sounds
expensive do you want ten thousand
dollars oh my god are you serious
they're mad the gaming computer won
they're mad doofen smears one they're
always mad at who we pick
i need you to make sure we don't get in
trouble this time i would definitely do
my best to make sure it's unbiased
why does this look like where like the
evil aliens hang out in the movie ah
jimmy i've been expecting you
i don't know how to make a farm i need
this brick replaced
do it we're already off to event start
i'm so sad
the cows are sad i can hear them the
only person that really knows what a
farm looks like is chris
we can persuade him yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're playing the game right yo
look at this among us holy crap
this is not gonna win but it is cool
yeah that looks good yeah
that looks good trust the process
oh no carl what'd you do don't come in
here
is that dr phil this is dr phil how did
i know from all the way over
chris is on the other side of the room
and i'm like is that dr phil dr phil
send him to the ranch oh that is kind of
farming related while everyone is
building i need to address a controversy
and whatever you build i'll pay for
someone built their college degree and
in our opinions it wasn't the coolest
building and we went with this guy that
made a desk with three monitors it was
for the boys
so we're actually about to move that
person in this will be interesting
hello what's up matcha xp what did you
think of the video
it was a great video i'm glad the boys
got their pc
all right well there you go everyone
stop getting mad at us even he supports
the boys
i want to make things right and we're
actually going to give you 10 000
for your college education oh my god
thank you so much
yay everybody's happy awesome well thank
you for coming out we're gonna go back
to raiding farms
oh my goodness look at how epic
everything is and there's still 10
minutes left chris i always join the
chat it's your turn
you guys have eight minutes left that's
that's plenty of time
jimmy they said they want more time okay
seven minutes ladies and gentlemen i got
good news jimmy's giving you more time
it's seven minutes now destroy the timer
there we go
yeah baby and now dude look how perfect
this looks okay i'm not gonna lie
i'm a little bit proud time is now up
look at all the amazing stuff they built
here's the before
here's the after let's find the best
farm on this world
it's a cow getting milked i think i'm
gonna give it a six it's creative yeah
i'll give it a six too
i'm gonna give it a seven that is a 19
out of 30. next uh it's like
technoblade's farm ah that's creative
not organized enough next this is an
actual minecraft farm 50 grand is on the
line
next uh this is just a hillbilly that's
a guy farming look he's got his hose
oh oh and the little sapling
oh that's team trees right that's like
the logo yeah i like it
really creative i'm gonna say six though
so
seven for me oh is that twenty new
winner all right so he is now in first
place
this one just says help up next we have
mr phil
i just qualified it whoa we're just
disqualifying doctor phil like that
all right what are your guys's ratings
on this 7.3
horses are here cows are here like
that's really cool i'm gonna give it
eight i'm gonna give it a six
this is first place now giant techno
blade shrine what are we rating that
uh zero three all right tough crowd this
one kind of looks like
mario yeah it does if this egg spawns a
chicken i'll give him a six
next this build had a lot of effort in
it now that's a farm
oh my goodness gracious yeah this is
amazing this is really good
this is a solid eight from me eight from
me as well
it does it does look high effort i mean
i'll give it a seven it is now in first
place
this farm has among us on it next meal
he's got all that milk oh since there's
no milk in the chest we gotta egg his
house
all right egg his house he's probably
like why are they throwing eggs is that
good or bad i never know
is this supposed to be me you guys never
see the back of my head but little do
you know this mustache just goes right
here
all the way around the back of my neck
oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa yo this got a crop duster on it
what it does is it sprays the crops so
that way they don't get any bugs or
like other bad plants in them and then
you got the windmill for renewable
energy
and this guy's name is krusty435
i'm gonna give it a nine i'm gonna give
it eight i mean it is original he's got
the windmill not many people did that
he's got the crop duster i'll give it an
eight
25 in first so far we have now judged
everyone
the highest score is 25. i'm letting you
know right now dude you're gonna love
ours
it's worth it baby it's worth it is very
visually a pleasing
i spent so much time on it if you see
anything on the outside you say it's
visually appealing that is all
chandler's doing okay i did all of the
interior design
and we'll walk in here and then you're
like what are there no there's no
animals in this farm
we got a horse in the house you're like
oh that's all the interior design you
did carl
and welcome oh look at this
pig's boxing oh snap the pigs are about
the box
ding ding
what is your rating a solid 6.5 6.5
yeah who has two secret rooms and a
boxing ring i'm adjusting my score down
to five
this isn't that impressive you double
the manpower i think it was really well
put together
i'm gonna give it a 10. imagine spending
an hour just bone mealing so the whole
yard looks pretty and you get a thigh
krusty welcome to the cold wait krusty
how old are you i'm
17. you as a 17 year old just went up
against a hundred other people
you came out with the dove and won 50.
dollars oh my gosh [ __ ] you it was all
because of the crop duster krusty
oh i need something i need to slow my
dad done thank you again to america's
dairy farmers for sponsoring this video
and make sure to support your local
dairy farmers